hi you guys must be new to town we just
moved from California which is in
America oh we just wondered if you
wouldn't mind if your daughter played
with our daughter Audrey say hi
[Music]
slides off limits to Ching chongs
do you want to be best friends
to our daughter it's a big deal going
back to your birth country we used to
talk about it all the time a grand
adventure to find your birth mother who
needs more parents when I have the two
best parents in the world
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you both actually have a lot in
common you're both very sexually free
she blew Nick and Joe Jonas not Kevin
not impressed I am a good girl saving
myself for marriage I'm sure you don't
miss it
dead eyes coming by the way your cousin
like that eye where did that come from
you know I think I get it
[Music]
I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see an American what do
you do for work because the cops are
doing a back check
we can't get caught with drugs in China
get a plug are you gonna play
are they coming out yeah but only seven
and I think I put in eight just push
pull twist this
pops my
she never come to China people are
always thinking I have this perfect life
but I don't belong anywhere if you do
not know where you come from how do you
know who you are let's find your birth
mother will you guys come with me yes
hello
look at me
our passports are in my suitcase that
got stolen you know who can bypass
airport security K-Pop Stars
everyone remember their names sassy
cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't believe
these girls are singers girls
[Music]
yeah is she here there's some in
this house there's some in this
house there's some holes
in this house
[Music]